why isn't obi-wan kenobi pulling out his
lightsaber where is this missing
inquisitor and did anyone notice the new
adorable droid these are the details
they slipped by you in the second
obi-wan kenobi trailer the new trailer
marks the first glimpse of comedy actor
kumail nanjiani and if his wardrobe is
anything to go by the force might be
with him too nanjiani can be seen
hunkered down seemingly in hiding
interestingly his character who has yet
to be named is wearing threads similar
to the now eradicated jedi might
nanjiani's character be one of the few
like obi-wan kenobi that escaped the
fallout from order 66 if so being the
last remnant of the ancient order is no
laughing matter this series could mark
the actor taking on a more serious and
less quippy role than his fans are used
to and it may spell doom for his
character's fate given the risks of
being a jedi in this scary post revenge
of the sith world the highly anticipated
reunion between obi-wan and darth vader
is not the only obstacle the jedi knight
will have to face in the new series fans
of star wars rebels will recognize the
inquisitor's return to the star wars
narrative many inquisitors had once been
jedi themselves but after order 66 they
joined the empire and used their force
sensitivity to hunt down the remaining
jedi and other threats to the empire
the jedi knights are all but destroyed
and yet your task is not complete
inquisitor
though inquisitors are featured heavily
in the obi-wan kenobi trailer there is
one character who is missing seventh
sister was a main antagonist in the
animated series but she is nowhere to be
seen in the new trailer considering the
inclusion of both the high inquisitor
and fifth brother who both appeared in
rebels this omission may seem odd many
fans on reddit have commented on their
hope to see an appearance of the
character however there is some logic to
her absence when ezra first encounters
her in rebels seventh sister has a
specific mission many of the inquisitors
are trying to kidnap four sensitive
children but seventh sister is also on
the hunt for anakin's former padawan
ahsoka tano this could explain seventh
sister's absence in the events of
obi-wan kenobi it might indicate that
she'll instead be appearing in the
ahsoka tano disney plus series
while kylo ren's fiery lightsaber design
in the sequel trilogy is definitely one
for the books star wars die hards know
that there's no characters who play with
lightsaber construction more creatively
than the inquisitors the grand
inquisitor's lightsaber has a circular
motor of some sort surrounding its
handle allowing the lightsaber to rotate
like a helicopter's blades it seems that
inquisitor riva's lightsaber may serve a
similar function as shots of her using
her weapon in the trailer show a similar
half-circle handle guard of some kind
extending from one end of the
lightsaber's handle given the way
actress moses ingram and the series
executive producers have hyped up the
character in recent months expect it to
be used to help make riva a uniquely
terrifying villain obi-wan kenobi series
writer and executive producer joby
harold recently told entertainment
weekly that riva's addition to the
franchise will be a touchstone point in
the history of star wars bad guys ingram
for her part described the character as
athletic and driven towards completing
her mission it doesn't appear
unreasonable to think that riva may be
the one to truly give kenobi a tough
time throughout the series
another new star wars project another
cute droid to merchandise another toy to
add to your collection this brand new
droid has an interesting red and white
design with flaps on its back end that
almost appear to move like ears between
the red color scheme and black gloved
hand that it appears in it seems safe to
assume this droid belongs to one of the
inquisitors if not riva herself
throughout nine star wars films multiple
disney plus live action series and any
number of animated shows lucasfilms has
produced over the years we've seen
droids do everything from repairing pod
racers to piloting ships to scouting out
enemies surely this one will serve a
unique purpose toward the galaxy-wide
search for kenobi if the new droid looks
slightly familiar it may be due to the
fact that it somewhat resembles the very
top of a bb unit without the ball
underneath that it rolls under the
noises it makes certainly don't fall too
far from how bb-8 sounds throughout the
three most recent star wars movies those
take place decades after the new obi-wan
kenobi series though perhaps this droid
design is a precursor to the lovable
rolling ball that accompanies poe
dameron throughout the galaxy in the
sequel trilogy
between this trailer and the first
hair-raising teaser we got a few weeks
back one thing that both previews are
missing is something no jedi should be
without and that's a lightsaber obi
wants to be exact while anakin
skywalker's former master looks to be
getting into plenty of trouble in the
new trailer he's keeping most threats at
bay thanks to having a trusty blaster at
his side
so uncivilized
this begs the question what's going on
given that kenobi is undoubtedly trying
to stay out of sight of the empire it's
definitely true that firing up his
lightsaber might not be the smartest
move is there a chance that there's more
to it than that the last time we saw
kenobi sheath his weapon he'd left
anakin screaming in agony on the shores
of mustafar and watched the collapse of
everything he'd spent his life fighting
for did the infamous duel have a lasting
effect on the old jedi knight making him
reluctant to draw arms again could the
teased reunion between master and former
apprentice cause old friends to draw
swords once again it might just happen
if our hero is forced to do so check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite star wars shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]